Film Courage: Alex, when you teach actors, what lessons are you trying to drive home
to them?
Either creatively, personally?
Alex Sol: If I’m directing a play, I’m
trying to show the person that’s doing the
part, the work that there is a difference
between you know acting something and being
a human being and experiencing something,
sharing yourself.
What I’m trying to say is, from what this
was for me, why I got into it was the notion
that I could honestly share myself for other
people.
That human transaction was what it was all
about.
Period.
End of story.
That is what it was about.
So when I direct a play I try to maximize
the human experience of being a person and
what that really feels like.
And what that really sounds like is very different
when someone’s telling the truth versus
I’m clever and I know how to act something.
And that experience when you have the human
experience, it transcends like...that’s
a good actor.
It transcends that you affected me personally.
Do you understand what I am saying?
So that... what I would say is get real with
yourself and tell the truth in your work.
That is what I would say.
Question: What was the last acting performance
you saw that really affected you?